this week in
[Music]
feminism I mean yeah I hit him like
really hard but he was supposed to do
anything about it even was to sit there
and take
[Music]
it remember none of this is is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub for $89
annually join the fight at louder
with.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today what I know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it it that that doesn't help with neck
injuries what are you
doing but your neck is sore you didn't
lose the ability to speak I just want an
excuse to you the old Val
Kilmer oh my gosh so if you see me dead
today like if I'm moving around like
Michael Keaton's Batman that's that's
why I have this the whole thing you had
to raise the monitor because yesterday I
was like oh let's go to the
[Laughter]
clip she really put you in a neck brace
for a see collar oh it'll it'll go away
in a couple of days but uh you know hey
comment below that's you ever hurt your
there are only two ways to hurt your
neck how did you hurt your
neck wait what is this second so we are
going to discuss a few things look we
have the value with this show I'm
actually really glad that we get to do
this here in the morning sometimes we
get to break news before other people do
and then sometimes with the Evening News
cycle we have the value of of hindsight
we're able to look at the story as it
progressed and say oh people were wrong
about everything you were gaslit you
were lied to so we don't have to jump on
it and be first we get to actually
attempt to be correct so that's what
we're talking about today I think you
can hit the rund down there tool man um
the Gaza Hospital bombing as it's known
which uh may not even be a bombing just
to be clear well here's how you knew it
yesterday Israel bombed a Gaza hospital
now that's not true then you also heard
it might have been Hamas and you also
heard it might have been the Iron Dome
and there might have been a portion of
the rocket that split off and then you
also heard that it may be fire damage uh
most of these stories out there are
untrue and the timeline is certainly
convoluted and we'll get into the squad
uh and what they talk about not that you
care Jim Jordan is still not speaker who
really cares we'll also discuss Justin
Timberlake uh uh the bomb shell that he
apparently forced uh Britney Spears or
pressured her into having an abortion
which every wants to talk about but kind
of brings up the conversation of of
men's rights so that and more Gerald a
number two how are you sir I am doing
very well sir better than you neck wise
at the very least yeah yeah well I mean
that's saying something yeah thanks for
getting aali going and
uh when you hear this it's the funniest
man alive very happy to have him on mug
Club you get to watch him Monday through
Thursday 5:00 p.m. Eastern and you can
check out his dates at Nick dip.com Mr
doollo how are you sir good what
happened sound just cut out did it yeah
and your
headphones we need to adjust his uh does
he need playing with me H likely can you
hear now I can't hear enough check check
one two what is this a Tandy
product got another one of those voice
box yeah I know that's probably probably
just short circuited it oh Lord all
right you hear now yes terrific hi Nick
hi Nick these are realistic headphones
yes there you go this is accurate to
scale it's like it's actual size
remember that when I used to do the
Airhead shoes in comic books actual size
then you go I used to put them Side by
I'm like that's not actual size they're
full that's what she said all
right who was just breathing so loud
that it rumbled my headphon you know who
it was me Nick I'm in my late '90s I get
yes you have awake I got a you have
awake apneia I don't know what the hell
that
was I just lost my breath for a second
looking at you you're so
handsome that sounded like a fat guy in
a van by a gra that was a phone
call like a bulldog all right let's uh
before we go to thatth here here's one
of those things where people talk about
the barely pbls well now I guess the
barely pbl with transgender and actually
hold on it's a live show Monday through
Thursday and if at any point you see
this this while you're watching on
YouTube it's which head on over to
rumble which is probably going to happen
very soon repeatedly yes yeah so here's
a trans person uh you know you've heard
of people being a beer this is a trans
person actually trying to hide
[Music]
uh
p
[Music]
a
yeah and no one can actually tell it's
oh you get to declare it it didn't this
didn't used to be the case not just
before we go to trans you didn't get to
declare yourself beautiful like I'm a
pinup model no you're not nope are you
pinned up anywhere yeah then no you're
not yeah get up model yeah that's what
they just say like oh yeah you're yeah
well you're not so much bombshell Betty
as you are um
disgusting Buffalo Bill had you know
that was a that was a cal he had it put
the makeup on the F
man couldn't couldn't tell I was a great
big fat lady this morning and PST the
makeup on the F
man it's like a chorus to a song how you
going to hide your penis it covers a
soul patch or it gets the H
again seven minutes in thank you Gerald
yeah no come on all right by before we
move on by the way uh uh my heart goes
out to Alex Jones who was supposed to be
here yesterday and he was incredibly
sick and then I it was like for one of
those 24-hour bugs only was about 12
hours let me guess so A throat yes um I
think that's throat can't he's goingon
to need one of these very
soon no doubt uh and uh we he will call
me Gerald knows us like at 9ine at night
so he was on his way driving to the
studio guy was a trooper and then he's
been apologizing Alex you have nothing
to apologize for no one in this industry
questions your work ethic he was
throwing up violently for about 12 hours
and then he started feeling better still
tried to make the Trek but you've heard
me talk about this he will leave me
these voice messages as
texts and he leaves him as though he's
talking with someone who's actually
responding I get them all the time uh
and this was the voicemail he left for
me when he was on his way at the tone
please record your message all right I'm
on my way to the studio but uh I don't
know I'm not feeling well it could be
some bad clams we don't know yet but
it's guys it's coming up all that I I
got to go
back like Alex you you don't need to
narrate it yeah feel better champ I love
that he's EA I love that he's eating
clams in Texas it's a great idea what
did you expect was going to happen I
used to have these people uh who were
friends who they would make me go eat at
the at a Crab Shack in Chicago like I
got the best uh they have the best snow
crab in Chicago of course we're getting
food they fly it in today they always do
it's all Frozen even if you buy it in in
in Maryland you're still getting frozen
crab I went to a Crab Shack in Chicago
little Viet me girl scratching for a
week and you couldn't tell that morning
she was a
man we love you a long time I love you a
long
time I don't really want to spend a
whole bunch of time on this I like Jim
Jordan he lost his first round of the
voting for the speaker of the house so
and by the way you guys can hit the like
button whatever you helps with the
YouTube algorithm because they want you
to think that we're dead uh the bet is
still ongoing M because we don't know
how many rounds there are going to be so
you can send your bets in to uh me on
X wow I like it it's not so much Vegas
as it's really more Atlantic City yeah I
just pictured a 9-year-old lady hitting
the nickel slots with an oxygen tank
next to I'm gonna go buy some teeth in a
hip
but you're you're playing penny slots
you're not going to buy a hitp I'll get
there eventually aluminum uh so anyways
here's a quick update on Jim Jordan how
he lost the first round from the Six
Flags guy with a toue the tellers agree
in their tallies that the total number
of votes is
432 Jim Jordan of the state of Ohio has
received 200 votes The Honorable hakee
Jeff of the state of New York he say
theal re 212 votes he said honorable I
thought he said the animal received a
majority of the whole number of votes
cast by Sur name the speaker has not
been elected all right so the BET
continues it does for a while do we want
to go right now to former Vice President
Biden see say yeah for me that means a
two-state solution sh my play a Thro Jer
for Israel's greater integration with
his neighbors these attacks have only
strengthen my commitment and
determination and my will to get that
done yeah I can hear it your voice here
to tell you the terrorist will not win
what terrorist unprecedented support
pack
money money money so let me end where I
began Israel You're Not Alone 1940 the
United States stands with you oh that's
great I told the story look at the L
Biden to others thinking of attacking
Israel
Min I sitting across from gold in my ear
I I don't know if that was done
emphatically or he just had a he just
had a lapse in memory like don't he just
said he had gold in his ear that turn it
back up just before the 1973 yam kapor
War up and she flipped the maps
up and down telling me how bad things
were and how terrible they were all of a
sudden she looked at me and she said
would you like a
photograph I looked at her she got up
from desk and walked out into that
hallway I think it's Marble
for that's what a liar does right they
give these details like was mar mar CH
of him there was uh a lion yeah that's
the ticket and it was made from uh it
was made from
slab granted could have been ignas
sedimentary worried like of course I'm
worried coniferous he's dying in front
of us I know this guy is dying in front
of us yeah this is uh and by the way
we've talked about this and you know I'd
still love to hear your feedback uh I
think that the moral support that Israel
has the right to do whatever they need
to do to defend their country that
doesn't equate to certainly American
bodies or sending more money this is the
issue you have you have a
country that needs to defend it okay in
the face of right surrounded by people
who want to wipe them off the face of
the map but then you have the United
States if Israel is the little devil
right the USA is the big devil according
to Hamas and Hezbollah depending on the
day and we also we jockey for position
every now and then but we fund all sides
of the war can we at least agree to stop
funding all sides of the war how about
that how about no money to Iran like
let's hit the comment button there to
can by what was Biden doing in his late
20s early 30s meeting with goldem yeah
is research can we check on this there's
no way this is true is this Molly's
Diner Amy's Diner am Diner remember that
when he talked about he used to go to
Amy's Diner every day and it didn't
exist like I used to go down back when I
back when I was SC is that what he I go
down Amy's Diner yeah yeah and and I me
I met the pope and he's he likes La Sy
thought I was a chef's
hat there it was like Amy's Diner had
been closed for 32 years he's talking to
the head chef though hey hold on you got
to you got so so we need you're don't
don't don't we have that section do we
all right let's see how bad it was my
message to any state or any other
hostile actor thinking about attacking
Israel Remains the Same as it was a week
ago don't don't
don't FS you know why he's repeating
that cuz he said it on a Sunday morning
no in 60 minutes yeah and Scott P had to
finish it p goes don't what don't come
over the Border don't don't finish my
sentences yeah ell had to walk him
through it I'm not going to take my
advice from a walking haircut that that
speech was maybe 10ish minutes long did
you see how he he was much stronger
there his stamina to like I'm really I'm
running out of juice guys do anything
like me and the SEC I don't know how
they inter does it 10 minutes that's not
so bad keep going yeah Gerald's Gerald
Gerald just stop you do you have any
idea how damning you are of yourself do
we have by the way actually let's just
cont do we have the this week in Biden
yes all right so you know what let's
contrast that with what what what is
this because we had a bunch of this week
this is this is him speaking at a press
conference and just this our president
he's speaking with Benjamin Netanyahu
trying to show support show American
strength solve and here's what he had to
say this weekend Bon Listen to If you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black you know uh years ago I asked the
Secretary of State when he and I are
working in Senate to write something for
man he said uh he wrote a line that uh I
think is appropriate he said uh it's not
we lead uh not just uh well I won't go
into it I'll wait to later taking too
much time if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're from me or Trump and
you ain't black all right we get it oh
my God he's an idiot he was going to
offer a light of like this is really
sweet innocent like this is perfect for
the moment forget about it and hold on I
forgot the line but I'm taking too much
time and then I'm seeing him they go to
the lady with Harry forearms I don't
know what they're thinking she's the
front and center lady now after the
Trump interview she is their main person
she has the gift you know that's what
Pops Pops Crow my dad walked by one time
he just walked by start on the monitor
he goes you know she has hairy forearms
he just kept
walking and all of us go that is
absolutely true she used to have a
unibrow too she did she looked like the
unibrow baby on The Simpsons all right
Sarah San has hairy for well yeah but
that's more of a princip Williams
yes it's like what Harve Harvey
firestein all right so wrong yes let's
uh let's go here just this is something
that okay
it's cultural it's well it's cultural
but here's the thing um this does bring
to light some other issues that a lot of
people sort of gloss over you know men's
rights uh and by the way when I say
men's rights people will say they can
say this about any anyone right oh black
lives matter are human trans rights are
human rights any minorities groups
rights are human well that's true human
rights are certain inalienable rights
mean you're owed with them by your
creator but we have uh one subset of
people as it relates to having children
in this country who have no rights the
mother has rights and then the child
once they're born according to the left
has rights often the father does not so
this is a flip side of that uh but I do
think that uh it exposes an underbelly
that we we need to know about here in
the United States so in our Memoir uh
Britney spr we're using that term very
Loosely by way we are yeah Memoir phaed
ramblings maybe yes um she talked about
how she had to uh or she was pressured
to have an abortion at the behest of
Justin Timberlake when she didn't want
to Britney Spears is sharing a painful
experience she's kept private for 20
years years people can confirm that in
her upcoming Memoir the woman in me the
pop icon reveals that while just in
timlake she became pregnant but she had
an abortion in the book Spears writes
that timble quote definitely wasn't
happy about the pregnancy he said we
weren't ready to have a baby in our
lives that we were way too young even
worse Joy faton pushed her down the
stairs now that's it's a lifetime movie
she said if it had been uh left up to me
alone I never would have done it and yet
Justin was so sure he didn't want to be
a father at the time he was 18 she was
17 and uh we'll go into men's rights but
actually this is something we get
exclusives here you know if you guys
support mug club with mug Club
undercover we've obtained an exclusive
audio um of the physician though we warn
you that it may be disturbing to some
[Music]
[Applause]
viewers to be clear the medical school
was not accredited
least the doctor likes Enigma yes it's a
good song A lot of people don't realize
uh but she came up with the song oops I
Did It Again in the waiting room at
Planned Parenthood no see that was
Sherry that was Sherry Shepard oh was
that Sher Shepard I'm sorry I confused
this it's easy to confuse by the way
she's dead by the way Sherry Shephard no
Britney Britney Spear you actually think
she's dead I don't ask me how my wife
follow you you guys you can't just say
don't ask me
how ask how I haven't you cackling
I haven't finished
[Laughter]
feel free here's some more rope Nick go
ahead all right do you have inside you
have the inside I
don't I really
don't I just uh I don't think she looks
healthy no no no I'm there's a Theory
online look you guys read about MK alter
and all that she was a Disney she
was a you know what right the Disney
Club and all that they sunk their
teeth into a lot of those people she's
one of them and I'm not the only saying
there's a there's a Theory online and
people have time to follow it unlike you
and I half the videos you see today are
not her yeah they're not her she's been
dead for a while think Micky Mouse Club
go online don't take my word for it take
the idiots online for it no but I'm
telling you research get on this I am
telling you I know the theory I time to
look it up myself I had to cut the grass
I have I've spent time uh looking up the
theory and uh no I don't buy it uh you
have I do think there there could be
some videos that maybe aren't her but I
don't that jump from she's gone she's
gone nothing we can do about it she's
gone yeah well that's a different stage
of grieving I guess I'm telling you I'm
telling you she's gone so this does
bring up though the issue where people m
a
ghost discuss
men's go ahead I love how we started
with definitively she's absolutely dead
like no I don't I don't have the no I
absolutely not I don't but just go
online you sound like an old Net Zero
commercial I need to go online sometimes
but I don't have the money n zero when
you're done with the show even your
conservative old crusty people out there
like myself are going to back me on this
okay all right I'm telling you you know
what you guys you can follow him and let
us know comment below if you buy comment
below let's see or you know what here in
real time hit the like button if you're
watching that'll let us know uh however
many thousands of likes we see means
that you believe Nick and maybe on mug
Club will go into that theory a little
more do you want to see a couple
examples like she put a picture up about
a year ago her at her wedding she
married that Sam whatever guy and she's
got uh all these famous people next her
Jennifer Anderson and stuff and Madonna
and her and her hand is sinking into
Madonna's you could tell it's pixelated
that could just because Madonna is
basically zip ties and Play-Doh well
she's demonic yeah maybe Madonna thing
I'm telling you yeah I'm telling you
look I dated the
broad all right I'm really lying so this
definitely is he damt it he dreamt it
that's what happened I'm telling you she
de bad mushrooms but this does bring us
you know people talk and they get
horrified they go oh I can't believe
that Justin like would and I Do by the
way think that's a crappy move to
pressure woman now that being said on
the flip side and this is something that
a lot of people have dismissed when
people are discussing men's rights there
are a lot of men who have no legal
recourse if they're in a consensual
relationship with someone and the woman
becomes pregnant and he wants to raise
the child this happens all the time so
this is one thing that a lot of people
don't and all the references are
available lc.com um for example the law
does not require a spouse's consent for
um an abortion at all or even letting
him know in some states it's considered
unconstitutional uh but then you have on
the flip side so in other words a man
could say okay look we both want to have
this child or you don't even want to
have the child but I will raise the
child that is that is my blood that is
my DNA right that is my air that is my
lineage I want this boy girl whatever uh
no say woman may not even tell him and
then once the child is born okay he has
to pay he has to sustain the life and
pay child support now I'm not saying
that you shouldn't support the child on
the flip side of that though is we also
have a lot of men who are saying you
know what I'll pay double the State
child support but I need to be able to
see that's going to the child not to the
mom so there everyone in this equation
has rights except for the father of the
child right men are effectively
relegated to being walking sperm donors
and wallets and so we can just look at
it and get horrified and say I can't
believe that what a monster just in
Timberlake but I would also say that a
woman who simply goes out and aborts a
child that is half that father without
letting him know unilaterally is equally
monstrous I don't know how to tell you
guys this Justin timbery dead oh come on
not him too this is when I wish we had
Alex Jones he he would he would be on my
side yeah I'm telling you somebody call
Alex see if Brit I think he did it yeah
and and when we're dealing by the way
talking about child support for example
91.2% of the recipients uh are mothers
right mothers are the custodial parent
80% of the time despite the fact that uh
child abuse takes place uh to a higher
degree in single mother households uh
98% of people in the country receive
alimony are women so this is the issue
that I'm talking about here is when you
look at the stats that young men don't
want to get married it's because because
they have been relegated to the role of
being a sperm donor and a wallet and
that is a problem for women because a
lot of women are saying there are no men
in this generation who want to marry
them and the abortion issue really does
highlight it oh no vagina no opinion
well that doesn't even work anymore
because you have that barely passable
covering up his mustache there's no
vagina there but I guess they're allowed
to have an opinion why is the father of
the child not allowed to have an opinion
outside of paying money yeah I mean
that's that's got to be a painful
experience for guys because you and I
were talking about this you've made the
decision to have sex right right so
there was the decision point was further
back along the line you make the
decision to have set we don't know that
she can set to but go ahead well let's
assume that she did for the sake of
argument Britney consented yes you you
choose to have sex and then a pregnancy
occurs and you're you're completely
pro-life right and this person chooses
to go a different direction like that's
that's a a huge loss like that's one of
the things about having abortion for
convenience that Society has kind of
foisted on us a bit that creates a situ
where nobody wins right the mom later on
down the line most likely the issue is
this is just another demonizing of the
man where it's easy to do but no one
actually talks about the the the
statistical problem in this country
these are not being made uh as
co-parenting decisions as far as as it
deals with abortion as far as how it
deals with raising children right now in
this country we have a legal system that
a lot of people dismiss folks out there
who are quote unquote redpilled or you
know men's rights activists but hey
there's also we've discussed the draft
which could happen really quickly you
saw what happened with Israel right and
right now we have a recruitment problem
so men are eligible for the draft okay
and men have no saying what happens to
their children okay everyone has rights
in this equation except for the father
and I'm just letting you know out there
there are a lot of dads who feel like
well okay I'm nothing more than a wallet
and a sperm donor and that is not a good
place to be uh as as Western society and
you know what else this is where
everyone else across the world they look
at the Western and they laugh at us this
is where they do laugh at us this is
where they have a point this
genderbending issue we've screwed up
some issues here we definitely have we
need to take some there needs to be some
culpability all right a wallet and a
sperm donor yep yep well I mean in the
case just described it every
John well I don't know if they have them
anymore there's so many people who are
dead the in memorium this year is just
we should have Nick Apollo drafted up
the in memorium I'm telling you Alex
will be he'll back me up a thousand
leave by
alone she's dead we should have seen the
warning signs with that with Chris
Crocker like oh this is going to
everyone's going to be that mentally
unstable right now we just think a funny
viral video pretty soon they'll be
claiming to be women and covering up
their mustache with with concealer all
right so this brings us to the story
from yesterday you know Israel uh Gaza
the hospital bombing exactly F this is
what well you get concussed right from
the media there was so much
misinformation and by the way I will say
some on both sides but particularly the
misinformation coming from Hamas and the
mainstream media um I don't take the
idf's word for it and by the way
military operations need to sometimes be
covert they need to sometimes misdirect
that's not the same as the media
reporting something with no vetting
whatsoever so when you see these stories
and we will walk you through the
timeline because I want you to
experience it in real time as we were
kind of experiencing uh this yesterday
there were so many different stories so
many different theories it's hard to
parse Truth uh from fiction so if you
were watching let's let's start with
this Marley was dead to begin with if
you were watching the news yesterday
right late early evening I guess you say
after dinner time right you probably
heard that Israel blew up a hospital now
this is not we know beyond any shadow of
a doubt to be clear this is not true now
but there have been three or four
different stories reported since then my
question to you is what happens to
someone who just sees the Nightly News
at 6:30 or 7 and then Tunes out you have
people walking around right now right
now it's 10:30 Eastern who still believe
what they watched last night throughout
all the mainstream media that Israel
blew up a hospital in
Gaza the breaking news the devastating
scene out of Gaza where Palestinian
authorities say at least at least 500
people were killed Palestinian Health
authorities say the hospital was struck
by an Israeli attack a hospital in Gaza
City in the northern end of Gaza taking
a direct hit from an Israeli air strike
they saying his nose is trying to escap
his 300 people have been
killed by the Gaza Health Ministry the
death toll in the aftermath of an
Israeli what's believed to be an Israeli
air strike that caused a blast at that
hospital
more than 500 people are now dead okay
so then let's go to about 8 to 9:30 okay
local uh Israel time 9:30 p.m. tweets
headlines all over blaming Israel for
the strike right so uh we have Reuters
uh we have uh who else we have Jackson
hankle we have Reuters uh can you bring
up the collage there yeah yeah look
where Israel just bombed the national
Arab Hospital in Gaza they reportedly
dozens of dead and wounded why is the
media ignoring this as you just saw they
weren't ignoring this this is what they
do right they blame they blame you of
doing what it is exactly that they are
doing that's solinsky 101 Andrew
Breitbart was the first guy to highlight
it and it wasn't just
influencers Rashid Tay member of the
squad right tweeted this at 9:06 p.m.
the timing matters the timing matters
and you'll see why Israel just bombed
the uh Baptist Hospital killing 500
Palestinians doctors children patients
just like that President you know pus
this is what happens when you refuse to
facilitate a ceasefire and help
deescalate yeah Nick you about to say
something I was just going to say this
proves that the Jews don't run the media
that's a good point seriously Kanye
weeps no it's Classic Mr w h but she
immediately went to and everybody went
to this line women children because
they're telling heart strings of every
single person and as this goes on I hope
that pisses you off a little bit more as
you find out the truth of the story as
we go yes because like we've talked
about uh as it related to co it's not
this is what we knew at the time no no
you have to go back and say was there
other information did it exist at that
time and you ignored it anyway for
example was there other information that
said the vaccines won't actually
immunize you against Contracting the
virus yes it did exist was there other
information at that time that said
lockdowns don't work yes that existed
you chose to ignore it there are people
who continued to cover this story after
at least part of the truth emerged
definitively that it was not Israel who
you know firebombed the hospital that
did not happen we don't know all the
details but we do know that that is a
lie and that lie came from pro-islamic
terrorist sympathizers Al jazer just to
be clear and it was taken hookline and
sinker you just saw that number go from
dozens to 500 in the span of an hour and
by the way this we can go back to then
uh T's response member of the squad
threat to the National Security of the
United States of America and I say that
about a hint of hyperbole uh it echoed
what AOC said I believe this was
yesterday about I think this is the clip
of the ceasefire that went viral and I
think the position from Israel's
perspective is that there was already an
attack and Hamas already committed an
attack after that happened
do you really believe that they should
not respond to that oh I think what is
important in terms of response is Israel
does have a right to to
self-defense I Ed a about in this
situation is if Collective punishment
qualifies as defense yes it does yes it
does what do you think defense
is writing save the dates this isn't
them going after all of the citizens
Gaza this is them going after
Hamas themselves that ties into Rashid T
andon Omar the collective they want you
to believe that look targeting women and
children as Hamas does as these
Palestinian terrorist organizations do
is not the same as using violence to
protect your women and children I can
use a gun to rape I can use a gun to
stop a rape it is that I can use a bomb
to kill women and children or I can use
a bomb to stop the killing of women and
children it is that's reductive sure I'm
fine with it now during these initial
reports just to be clear all of that
information that you saw from the
mainstream media it came from quote
unquote the Palestinian government
that's what they said yes you know what
that means meaning and this is at the
same time the IDF said hold on we were
investigating this did not come from us
yeah but do you know what the
Palestinian government means means Hamas
yeah exactly it means Hamas they didn't
put that on the lower third they didn't
say Hamas says they said Palestinian
government hoping that you wouldn't make
the connection that Hamas giving us all
of this information that's false by the
way the minute the sun comes up you
figure out it's false yeah and by the
way just so you know because we say oh
not everyone voted for Hamas it's not
like a parliamentary system like oh
Hamas how many seats do we have will we
have a veto power it's all
Hamas it's all Hamas these days guys
yeah uh here we go to 9:30 p.m. at the
Timeline uh the IDF issued a report
blaming Hamas okay uh and they were
saying look you can't just follow these
tweets and just take them without any
any kind of a critical everybody kept
blaming Israel no matter what they said
they didn't have all of the information
but they did say this was not we do know
that this was not one of our strikes but
ilon Omar after that at 101 12 p.m. on X
still xed out I guess we don't say tweet
anymore bombing a hospital is among the
gravest of war crimes the IDF reportedly
blowing up one of the few places the
injured and wounded can seek medical
treatment and shelter during a war is
horrific president needs to push for an
immediate ceasefire to end this
Slaughter Russia Today had up there more
than 500 people died in the hospital
missile strike in Gaza with about 600
more injured what uh and this media
report was citing uh the gods and health
Ministry now here you even have the BBC
by the way at 10:08 p.m. on air and
again look let's just say at this point
in time Hamas says one thing IDF says
the other you don't like Israel fine you
do have to agree that it's a 50-50 split
now I would argue this is just a matter
of opinion that Hamas has a history of
being slightly more
dishonest uh that's me Mr traditional so
at 10:08 p.m. the BBC preemptively
discredits the IDF reports live on here
the Israeli military has been contacted
uh for comment and they have said that
they are
investigating but uh you know it is hard
to see what else this could be really
given the size of the explosion other
than an Israeli air strike or several
air strikes uh because you know when
we've seen Rockets being fired out of
Gaza uh we never see uh explosions of
that scale we might see uh half a dozen
maybe a few more people killed in such
rocket attacks but we've never seen
anything uh on the scale of the sort of
explosion on the video I was watching
earlier uh which as you say is still to
be verified by the way this is what I
call the feminist defense where it's you
know they'll be going world starring a
guy and then it's you can't you well you
can't defend yourself against a woman
you wouldn't hit a guy with glasses
would you he's insulting them well
listen even though they're saying that
it wasn't in fact them Hamas sucks so
bad there's no way in hell they could
have inflicted this kind of damage it's
sad really I mean they fire Rockets up
in the air when they're celebrating yeah
they no idea what they're doing they
failed everything they're harmless
they're helpless they're what the French
call leenon so we're going to say Israel
we're going to blame the Jews mate yeah
well look I I want to I want to be clear
the the reason that we cited Russia
Today in the BBC is because these are
the PE like Al jaer will come up next
right we've got them saying this as well
that is the People speaking to the the
Middle East they're speaking to Europe
they're speaking to the people in the
region to get them going on this story
it's not just Western media like us
saying the wrong thing which they're
still saying right now on CNN Biden and
Israel after devastating blast at Gaza
hospital it blew up cars in a parking
lot well hold on we haven't gotten there
I know I'm just saying that's another
thing you may not know the devastation
is not what they claimed we'll get to
that we'll get to that so it was
self-inflicted for sure there is video
Just to be clear we don't know exactly
who was firing we don't know exactly the
intent but we do know that it was
self-inflicted at this point and we do
know that it was not nearly as damaging
as the initial report so the initial
report was F Well dozens but then 500
dead because of Israel in this massive
bombing yeah both of those are untrue
now it's two Vol two Volkswagens and a
Vesper or what the Honda Cubs you ever
see what they do in Vietnam with those P
they have like a entire family and a
coupe of chickens going uphill so at
10:57 p.m. Israel and they provided
video and this is the thing they have to
provide video because they won't be
believed uh they provided CNN with the
evidence the bombing was a failed rocket
launch by and I know this sounds very
generic because when I say Palestinian
Islamic Jihad that's actually the
organization it's like it's
was it president select version of
terrorism it is yes it's brand terrorism
yeah could do like you're all Islamic
Jihad you can't just add a Regional
Title so Israel provided this evidence
that the bombing was failed uh by that
organization and here's it's a low
quality clip but we'll give you some
more evidence after that this was
provided the important fact that I can
say now for the first time on CNN is
that we did not strike that and that the
intelligence that we have suggests that
it was a fake failed rocket launch by
the Islamic Jihad yeah there you go it
was a rocket the fact that it's on CNN
gives it some credibility but people is
going to poo poo that yeah it's a
Israeli guy just lying I mean that's
what you're going to hear right but you
know it's not a real far leap to to
think that um the Islam Hamas you know
is trying to shoot off a rocket near a
um hospital because they use those
hospitals as human Shields it's not a
real stretch right exactly that's what's
so
funny your friend said out Josh military
guy Oh I thought we were talking about
the BBC guy you actually mean a real
person yeah yes who did 21 months in in
Afghanistan thank you for service
absolutely abely and uh he's like he
said you don't see any incoming there no
not that you'd see a lot he said but but
that's kind of a good point isn't it
yeah it is it's odd to believe it's odd
to think of how this could be something
else it's odd to think of how innocent
civilians in Palestine could be killed
by anyone other than Hamas sorry
IDF like what what do you mean it's hard
to think it's the most logical
conclusion this happens all the time
come on guys and this isn't new by the
way this is something that happens
everywhere it's it's Universal right
people are driven by ego everyone plays
the blame game they do it in the west
they do it in the East they even do it
here in the office it's been a problem
all morning no one wants to take
accountability are they still
[Music]
up
oh someone set off a bomb in there it
wasn't me
I know it was you it wasn't
me
[Music]
Gerald was he supposed to be enjoying
that it's like he walked into a
Starbucks I just I just cut the checks I
hate all of you so let me give you some
some more information here okay the
following information just so you're
clear all the references are made
available at L with credit.com Link in
the description it's uh all from uh open
source intelligence I think the account
is osin NT I believe on X uh and uh this
has been by the way uh supplemented um
by Israeli media as well and the IDF
because we already provided you with the
Intel from uh well from Hamas and from
the Islamic jihadist BBC but I repeat
myself so here's another video that
shows a non-israeli ET was intercepted
or it or it failed most likely most
likely failed there's an argument to be
made that this probably wasn't
intercepted because of how close it was
still to you know Palestinian quote
unquote territory uh but near the
vicinity here this video is is very
close to the the hospital in
question so you see something looks like
it failed there looks like it failed
there and then they pan out and and then
it there you go and then it looks like
you know it looks like a cluster bomb at
that point here's an alternate angle um
from uh is Israel's I guess it's a CET
yeah caset I don't know the singer it's
the the news station brush their teeth
with a bottle of jacket this is a ring
doorbell show
yeah you'll notice the white robber yes
so uh this was released this morning
this is a channel 12's camera it is a
camera situated in the city of netivot
and
the Gaza Strip you see the time uh stamp
on this it's
659 and this is when it happens we can
press play on the tape and you can see
very clearly again this is channel 12's
camera um you can show the you can see
the Rockets this is the uh left red
stamp fired over the hospital which is
the right and you can see the blast so
that is proof of the fact that it came
from the Gaza Strip so there you go you
see that now don't believe you're lying
eyes and ears and by the way Andrew Tate
I will say he he uh reached out he
tweeted me exed me look I don't want to
start because he was pretty respectful
and actually he has some points in his
criticisms that I think are misguided
but valid uh so I'd like to invite him
on the show but he was arguing that
Hamas and a lot of people are making
this argument that they don't have a
powerful enough military they don't have
that kind of artillery yeah so Andrew
Tate said Israel admitted it no I don't
know what that's coming from um Hamas
Rockets are not that powerful uh and the
Servants of the uh the the bicent
beneficent is that what it is no
beneficiary beneficent God beneficent
God beneficent are they who walk on the
earth in humbleness admit you were wrong
thousands of children dying is peace
worth a conversation uh yet and here's
an interesting defense you know they
they use this all the time it's it
couldn't have been us because we suck so
badly you sure you want to go with that
defense it couldn't have been us what
because we're so bad at what we do we
couldn't build a rocket we come on we
don't even have Tinker Toys and by the
way it's believable because even if they
had the weapons you in the west would
likely assume that they wouldn't even be
able to fire
it so my point is it's a convincing
argument but it doesn't mean that it's
real so this is this is the funniest
thing for me is like you're trying to
strike fear in the heart of your mortal
enemy and you're saying we're going to
wipe you off the face of the Earth bever
good at doing this we are going to bring
to you the black death but you know that
means we'll get up around noonish I
don't somehow maybe over a way yes we
have a few sporks that's why I don't go
to firing ranges anymore it's the guy
next to me all the time looks at you and
you just hear the theme from Homeland
you're like I got to get out of here by
the way and I agree Andrew Tate has a
point on some of the criticisms oh can
we have that can people bring that up
for me the criticisms from our show
yesterday but about Islam but by the way
in his tweet the last thing in the world
that I would think of when I think of
Andrew Tate is humility so I have some
issues with you sir as well but it's
peaceful and it's fair it's just like
come on you're you're quoting a verse
about humility you know who you are
right well he has he has like nine
Lambos you were about to say something
there uh I'm just saying when you blow
something up if you hit a gas station
with a missile even a crappy one yeah
it's going to be huge explosion yeah it
doesn't even matter what does the
quality of the gas station have to do no
well you're not listening a f man of the
cloth get the wax out of your ears
that's what their plan all along and
they end blow times harder than a
freaking Target store we launched our
best rocket it wasn't even oygen tanks
didn't even have uned she needs premium
dude and by the way oh thank you for
on that great comment come
on by the way Hamas does have not just
Hamas but the Palestinian Islamic Jihad
don't confuse the two because they're
very different uh they do have rockets
that capable if you were to believe them
why because they claimed it and they
showed
us
good point
yeah that's a little firework it
could real it could be some styrofoam
red tape and hair
die like the point is I'm not taking
them uh at their word and just as a as a
small side Andrew Tate did he talked
about yesterday we had a segment on the
show mug Club specifically regarding the
Quran being incompatible um with the
Constitution Western values and I will
say Andrew Tate had a valid criticism
saying yes that Islam does not tolerate
the current state of the United States
now I've said this in the that is true
if you're talking about the Quran and
Islam not toting drag queen Story Hour
right I get it you have a point that's
misinterpretation of what we were
discussing what I was saying was that
the Quran is incompatible with the First
Amendment so not what we are living out
in the United States today which I get I
don't want to export this culture right
now American culture was a great thing
to bring to the rest of the world when
it involved Freedom right when we were
judeo-christian Nation so that's a valid
point from Andrew Tate what I am saying
is go back to the founders and the Quran
is certainly not compatible with the
First Amendment with the Second
Amendment you think Jews and Christians
are going to be allowed to have guns
under Sharia law for they have a curfew
dimude and a PO tax so I just want to be
clear his criticism there is one that a
lot of people make regarding the Western
world today there is validity to that
and we did an entire segment on it where
for the first time we are on the wrong
side morally culturally of history that
has nothing to do with the Quran being
incompatible with the founding documents
and and to be fair Andrew Tate was very
was pretty respectful in his
disagreement so I'd love to have him on
the if you would like to I know we've
kind of missed each other um and I think
it could be a lot more productive than
the uh you know terrorist who was on
Pierce Morgan well there's a group I
guess you didn't see queers for Hamas
did you see that yeah it's hilarious
unbelievable yeah unbelievable you know
blacks a Sickle Cell yes
exactly that's the
equivalent I mean do you guys have any
idea and by the way but they want to
have that both ways I go yeah Hamas
wouldn't tolerate uh drag queen story
okay I get it but you also shouldn't
just be throwing gay people off of
rooftop
there's a there's a split the difference
they were told they could fly they're
testing the theory yes exactly haven't
found them yet just Clap the fery will
live and bye so oh it doesn't happen and
hit the like button if you would like to
see uh you know um me and uh perhaps one
of the Tate Brothers have a conversation
on that and I don't again I don't want
this to be one of those oh you know
drama clickbait things no he was
respectful in his disagreement I think
his criticism is valid I think it was
misdirected because that's not the point
that we were making let's go back to
this here's some uh here's here's some
other evidence which I think Gerald was
really not upset about but you thought
was pivotal and a lot of people pivotal
and now upset yes yes now upset there
there's plenty of news footage and
images that show that the damage was
actually very minimal yeah okay there's
even Drone footage now yes this comes
from the IDF but again it corroborate
some of those other pictures there um so
the IDF is corroborating the ENT is just
like this is what's publicly available
it's not a specific account that's osen
on there there may be one of those but
it's like all of these different
accounts out there saying wait a minute
we have aerial footage now of the
hospital that was supposed to be bombed
that 5 or 600 people were supposed to
die in except the hospital's still
standing and it looks like five Kia blew
up in the parking lot and then the IDF
comes out and kind of corroborates that
so that's what we're seeing right now
jokes on you I'm a Hyundai man oh
now here is the the footage that shows
and we'll we'll point out here the
hospital let's show the
footage so see that right there that
shows basically before and after right
so there's Hospital compound Hospital
compound there's the parking lot yeah
the buildings next to the cars aren't
even blown apart there's the site of the
fire you got to be kidding I'm not
kidding this is ridiculous Hospital
parking lot the side of the fire now a
lot of people in those cars I mean
people could have died yes but of course
people could have died but the idea
again the first story that you heard was
Israel targeted a hospital and killed
500 people 600 more injured that was a
story that you heard at the very least
we know that that death total is
inflated at the very least we know that
it was not a rocket fired by Israel and
it seems as though the hospital uh may
not have actually incurred that much
damage it didn't the windows got blown
out and by the way if you're a hom if
were to believe that in other words if
you don't trust the source the others
are irrefutable the no footage right now
has been shown they have shown no videos
of Hospital on fire Hospital buildings
damage other than minor damage from a
blast that happened near it Windows
blown out stuff like that that happens
right I I assume that didn't kill 5 or
600 people Hamas can you let us know
because 5 5 or 600 people building it's
a building going down I understand
that's fine we don't want you on the
show Hamas maybe just tell C face timer
Sky I don't want them in studio but
here's here's one of the biggest
problems that I have with this The Jig
Is up the moment the sun comes up and
you see the hospital still there they
don't care and we'll get to why they
don't care they just need a little bit
of time because there are consequences
to propaganda that's the reason for
propaganda and those consequences
involve people being hurt this couldn't
be coming at a worst time in history
with the evolution of
AI it's just undermining it's really
hard believe what you see everybody's
trust you know I know guy I know
somebody who used to work at Disney they
have technology he killed Britney
Spears God I wish I would have snipped
his fingers listen um look at this but
they have technology they've been hiding
that's so good that would freak us out
as far as making movies so it couldn't
come at a worst time it seems like you
know what I'm saying it's a perfect
storm of World War I but then you have
to go with okay what are they not
providing uh you know to disabuse you of
the notion why is the Israeli Islamic
Jihad or pales sorry Palestinian Islamic
Jihad why are they not counterbalancing
what the IDF has released or
counterbalancing what the international
intelligence Community has releasing no
no here is the hospital on fire now I
wouldn't put it past them to light their
own Hospital on fire so that they would
eventually have proof that that would
but right now CN at this moment right
now house to vote on speaker as mid East
reels from hospital strike they're still
running a Chiron that makes it sound
like somebody bombed a hospital which
did not happen that we know the only
person that would bomb a hospital in
Gaza to most of the world is who Israel
that's the only that's that's the
implication of I can't see any other
logical conclusion at the BBC they're
still running that what it should say
right now is house to vote on speaker as
mid East finds out it was all a sham
yeah a car or at cars got blown up maybe
somebody did get killed that's a tragedy
I understand that but this story is
still being pushed out there as though
there's something nefarious going on
from Israel to this hospital or that 5
or 600 people potentially died the mid
East is reeling how about the mid East
is waking up and finding out it was it
was a goof it was a hoax no they they
launched a rocket and it failed don't
you just miss Donald Trump as president
at times like these like the world woke
up today and found out that Hamas are
lying isn't that right well no
hospital Bomb by the Jews that's
something they said could you believe it
I said yes I say it all the time
I say it all the time I say of course I
can believe it I'm they bomb a hospital
that's what they do not the Jews they
don't bomb the hospitals maybe a vending
machine maybe they
bummed so if you were tuning into the
media and this is why this matters
because some of us and this is why we
try to provide this show for you and by
the way none of this happens without
your support mug Club lit.com mugclub
you get Nick's full show every day you
get Nick's full show every day Alex
Jones on Friday when he's not throwing
up we'll do another 45 minutes to hour
of show here today Brian Ken hodin all
of that um but we stay on top of this so
that you don't have to and this is one
thing that I talk about quite a bit a
lot of people in the media they either
think you're an
idiot which is silly I don't know why so
many people revile Their audience like
CNN does um or they assume that you have
the time to devote to this like this is
our full-time job my interpretation is
you're a you're a smart person watching
listening right now you could be a
surgeon and you don't have8 hours at
night to follow this story along
especially if your Hospital's being
blown up yes exactly especially if
you're working a double forget about it
unless you're a nurse during Co then you
have nothing to do let dance um so
that's so so we try to put this together
for you because you have to also take
into consideration that there are people
who tuned in to the news last night at 7
o'clock and they are still walking
around right now and CNN by the way is
doing everything they can to continue
the LIE this isn't agreed upon lie
someone could still think that oh my
gosh Israel bombed a hospital targeted
women and children they're no better
than Hamas create a false moral
equivalent
and that can shape their opinion on the
conflict moving forward that's why the
timeline matters that's why accuracy
matters so if you were tuning into the
media yesterday before we actually had
some of the truth you know I guess it
was was peeled off here in layers um you
would believe that Israel definitely
blew up a children's hospital in Gaza
that hundreds were confirmed dead that
there were hundreds more who were
injured yes that's right a Baptist
hospital um and that uh that the
International Community was turning a
blind eye to which is kind of funny when
they say the International Community is
turning a blind eye while they are
discussing it none of that information
was correct that information was coming
from MOS the truth is that we know the
the the rocket was fired from within
Gaza failed landed in Gaza may not have
hit a hospital just to be clear may have
hit the parking lot and it's been
corroborated by the international
intelligence Community not just the IDF
don't always believe the first report
and it is your job to inform people who
do if you know better make sure they
know better yeah you hear somebody
talking about it at lunch H did you see
that Israel bomb no no no no no no no no
Islamic Jihad fired a rocket it misfired
it hit the parking lot and we don't know
the death toll but it certainly isn't
300 200 500 600 none of that and if you
work we SWAT it down Palestinians quit
Uber
listen what but let me push back a
little you say that right well we have
footage of the hospital Still Standing
couple of burnt cars what do you say to
the people say how do you know that's
real no that's well that's what that's
what I said about that specific footage
we do know the rocket was definitely
fired from within Gaza we have more
footage too I just
they sent it into US I've just chosen
not to bring it we don't have anything
from Hamas or sorry we don't have
anything from the Palestinian government
refuting the Ida in other words the best
thing they could do right now is going
no no look here's a hospital in ashes
there that doesn't exist as far as I
know what what you said wasn't the idea
who corroborated it you said there's a
there's a uh uh an unbi pretty good uh
Twitter profile that we F sorry X ENT no
no no no no I don't think ent's the
account I think it's War something uh
tell us what it War monitor or something
like that might be War monitor but
they're very clearent
open source intelligence it's not IDF
yeah it's open source they use open
source intelligence correct yeah that's
just a bunch of people on the ground
reporters other people putting out out
information and then you have the
official sources from IDF that come in
and back that up or you know corroborate
with what's being said so this the
problem too is what it created yes what
it created and CNN kind of glazed over
that they did a Lebanon protest that
there was something going on they showed
some something on fire right now but
what happened is the entire Middle East
at
9:00 went insane
thinking isuck a hospital in Gaza and
killed or people the the Iranians had
started to kind of slowly back away
knowing that the United States had sent
a carrier they had another carrier on
the way Israel's going crazy they're
absolutely not going to pull back and
Iran was like uh maybe we don't really
want this fight right now because we'll
lose and Hamas is basically thinking
okay well what do we do with this story
now that we now that we see that it did
hit close to a hospital and this is the
same media by the way who said that
Donald Trump was so irresp responsible
that he inspired 9112 right January 6
this what do you think happens when you
cover you cover ad not wall toall
covered saying that Israel bombed a
hospital targeting women and children
are there any consequences is that not
worse than make your voices heard
peacefully and patriotically think about
that for a second why are you not held
to the same standard so you just talked
about yeah people losing their mind uh
after this the initial protest no let's
not allow cooler heads to Prevail uh
there was a large group you know let's
just go straight to the Montage there
were a bunch of protests
um there was there were protests in
Jordan the big big one was the Israeli
Embassy in Jordan but Iraq turkey
Lebanon this started happening based on
irrefutably false
[Music]
reporting
yeah yeah these are the US embassies by
the way the first one was the Israel
Embassy in Jordan this this is US
embassies I think the rest of these
shoot Bott I know they're blaming us as
as well feel the wrath of a Roman
candles maybe they're right they don't
have the
equipment have you met my friend Mr
Cherry Bomb they don't make him anymore
sorry black
cats
black
MD80 they don't make m8s anymore kids
were blowing up pipes we have black cats
we have the zizzers we have the ones
that lighted kind of like a we have
sparklers the end
Chasers that's that's what
yes boy were those
disappointing I mean it would be easy to
manipulate those they're a little
emotional would you say religious zots I
mean it would be very easy to manipulate
them they don't want to know the truth
they're blinded by religion I'm I'm Noto
look at me I'm not Islam they're just
looking for a reason to go and protest
they're looking for a reason to do this
it has very real consequences so not
only in the protests that we saw last
night but think about all of the
recruitment videos if if they're good at
one thing yes go signed up you're
signing up basically to be a human bomb
right you got to have pretty good
marketing to get people to sign up for
that they are what I one of them called
me I ended up with a reverse mortgage
yeah said look look if I thought this
was a scam I wouldn't be here yes I
wouldn't have done it myself signed up
my parents too but
basically B they're going to use all
this footage they're going to use all
this footage see the world said this
they're never going to run the
correction of the story they're just use
this so it wasn't just last night and it
had bigger consequences with a planned
Summit yes there was a King Abdullah II
of Jordan I love that title um it's like
the iron Chic isn't even satirizing
these people anymore you're jaon so he
called off the summit that was scheduled
today with former Vice President Biden
the president of Egypt and uh the
Palestinian president it was called off
was called off as a result of the
misreporting as a result of the United
States at least you know our government
saying yeah it does seem upon assessment
that this was actually have failed
missile launching failed rocket
launching from your own people and the
UN by the way they're going to vote
today on a resolution and just to be
clear for a ceasefire in the conflict I
have said this time and time again
calling for a ceasefire after the
kidnapping raping murdering decapitation
of innocent people is calling for the
encouragement of unfettered terrorism
once people have been terrorized you
don't get to call a ceasefire before
Justice
[Music]
hey ceasefire ceasefire everyone calm
down hey ceasefire calm down
guys I smell Emmy
yes at the very least an MTV's greatest
kiss award yes great maybe a Razzy yeah
yeah they still do the Nickelodeon slime
ones probably I'd like to I'd like to do
get one of those yeah so that's
a that's a recap of everything that we
know at this point and comment below hey
did you have some information that was
wrong that was false did you get sucked
into it wherever you line up wherever
you line up uh in this conflict and by
the way there are reasonable discussions
to be had as far as uh funding I don't
think this should cost one American body
right correct all of us here and I don't
think that we should be funing both
sides of the war um and that is not an
anti-semitic view but that is separate
and apart from the moral stance of
Israel absolutely has the right to
defend themselves calling for a
ceasefire at this point I I would argue
is evil give that's sometimes the idea
of peace is evil just give peace a
chance hold on hold on women and
children raped murdered like there's a
reason that we all the one thing that we
can all agree on all these all these uh
you know iic religions as people say
even though we discuss the differences
yesterday Islam Judaism Christian we do
believe that Justice is important and
certainly as it relates to governing a
society we can all find common ground on
that and there is no judeo-christian
system of justice that involves people
committing mass murder getting off the
hook completely unfettered there's no
appeasing a terrorist Hamas doesn't want
peace you can have a one-sided
negotiation and browbeat Israel into
kind of having a peace where they just
have to wait to get attacked again
before they can defend themselves they
don't want peace stop talking about hey
let's just have peace in the region yeah
no how how is different than Nazis of
the 30s well the the big difference is
they don't hide it at least the Nazis
say like no no look look this is fine
they're just taking the shower yeah
that's true that's all I don't know if
this na like no we are Nazis they'll
call you a Nazi you're like wait hold a
second I'm not a Nazi like hey Nazi over
here Nazi like n you don't know anything
about that they're not they don't know
what they're talking about the real Nazi
is Trump yeah there you go wait a second
I I just want to be clear I want to kill
all the Jew je I say it I do it I wake
up it's the first thing I think about
it's the last thing I think about when I
go to sleep how am I not a Nazi he
doesn't know what he's talking about
just ignore him I'm a
Nazi I'm glad you did a voice otherwise
they're Nazis without they're Nazis
without any technology no they are their
their goal is obvious in the rest of the
world like that's why I say people need
to understand what's going on in the
conflict you can get lost in the weeds
in a lot of these things and I think we
do a good job of hopefully driving you
guys to what's important but this is not
going to stop ever Israel could do
everything everything that they're asked
to do and they could have more requests
of Israel and they could do everything
that they're asked to do and it will not
stop this these people don't want peace
they don't want land either they want
Israel gone they want the Jewish people
dead well I do here's one thing that I
will say the big difference between them
and Nazis uh and and and I'm saying this
because I'm trying to be as pragmatic as
possible I think it changes our approach
it's almost a difference between a
psychopath and a sociopath Hitler was a
psychopath okay just do we have we have
the Hitler Hitler bad just to be clear
just to be clear just so you know Hitler
bad all right hit bad just to be clear
bad but Hitler as bad as he was he um he
did believe that he was doing what he
thought was best for his people a very
limited sect of people right Aryans
exclusively um and he wanted to protect
them whereas Hamas just kill everybody
Hamas doesn't value the lives of their
own Palestinians in other words the
reason that Hitler was defeated was was
because at a certain point the casualty
numers are so high where he doesn't want
all of the people he presumably cares
about to die that is someone who you can
defeat when Hamas says you know what we
are going to use our people they don't
have a people they don't respect it is a
death cult it is not a war it's not even
a perverted Psychopathic Hitler bad make
sure people know Hitler bad Hitler B
Hitler bad an ideology but it was this
subversion of white hair uh sorry uh uh
you know white skin blond hair blue eyes
arens you know good protect them at all
costs and that requires getting rid of
the Jews Hamas is get rid of Everybody
by any means necessary until we reach
this one world domination of a caliphate
the way that you deal with them is
different you can defeat an enemy who
values life to some degree even if it's
exclusively their their team jersey you
cannot defeat an enemy who doesn't value
life at all and they seek martyrdom
because it's the only straight shot to
Heaven according to their belief what
you need to do is shame them they need
to be embarrassed that's how you defeat
Hamas they need to be embarrassed on the
international stage and of course you
kill as many as possible because you
know it's fun we're funding we're
funding both sides what do we get out of
it by funding both sides in this one
obviously money like anything else well
the what why are we funding both side
what's how's that benefit us misguided
it's misguided yeah it's misguided is
trying to appease the stance in the
International Community and they would
say we're not funding both sides they
say we just unfroze the $6 billion to
Iran yeah we just un freeze it how about
you freeze it back up how about you
steal it from them by the way if I can
fre youry that's my money I may not have
ownersh of it but it's my money that's
my it's my nuclear capability money and
I need it now come on guys call
AA Nick doollo 5:00 p.m Eastern we are
going to continue discussing this uh and
we're going to play would you rather
because it's a perfect Nick game on M if
you're watching on Rumble right now
click that button none of this happens
without you notice very few sponsors you
don't have 20 live reads here in this
show we are funed by viewers like you
and Andrew Tate you're welcome on the
show and I actually do appreciate the
way that he approached the uh the
disagreement as opposed to you know like
a lot of people just calling for me to
be killed that's true YouTube uh piss
[Applause]
off
[Music]
oh